pour le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que c'est la fin d'une année scolaire
hors de l'ordinaire chamboulée par la
pandémie on se prépare déjà pour leur
rentrée de septembre
on en parle avec josée scalabrini
présidente de la fédération des
syndicats de l'enseignement et nicolas
prevost président de la fédération
québécoise des directions
d'établissement d'enseignement bonjour à
vous deux bonjour je pense qu à pas mal
à dire sur l'éducation
après des semaines mouvementées
brièvement je vous entends sur l'
annonce de cette semaine sur la
réouverture de tous les établissements
septembre une bonne nouvelle joseph moi
j'ai le goût de vous dire qu'il ya eu
deux bonnes nouvelles la daille ya eu
des inquiétudes aussi maintenant on eu
le temps de se préparer faut y
travailler bonne nouvelle parce que tous
nos élèves seront la bonne nouvelle
parce que ce qui permet un développement
global de l'élève avec sa motivation
c'est toute la dimension des spécialités
qui seront au rendez vous pour les
inquiétudes je pense qu'on aura le temps
d'en reparler dans l'émission exactement
et nicolas oui effectivement c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour nos élèves
particulièrement pour l'ensemble de nos
élèves mais particulièrement le pôle aux
élèves une erreur qu'on sait qu'avec le
nouveau taux de raisons x 2 step à tous
nos élèves vulnérables qui était présent
aux primaires donc de savoir que
maintenant tout le monde va être à 100%
pour nous c'est vraiment une bonne
nouvelle russie il y aura des enjeux
bien entendu on sera prêts à y faire
face et on va parler de ses modalités de
la rentrée de septembre
après la pause mais d'abord revenons en
faisant un bilan un peu de cette année
scolaire inédit quel bilan faites-vous
josé c'était trois mois difficiles
difficile pénible pour les enseignants
mais qui ont été extraordinaires et qui
ont su relever le défi chaque fois que
les conseils n'ont été clair chaque fois
qu'on leur a demandé quelque chose et
ils ont été au rendez vous puis j'ai le
goût de faire un clin d'oeil parce que
vous venez juste avant nous de parler
des finissantes et finissants qui avait
pas une fin d'année comme il souhaitait
mais je doute vous dire qu'il ya
énormément énormément d'enseignants qui
ont connu la faim de retraite qu'ils
souhaitent librement
gens qui partent à la retraite et qui
aurait voulu finir différemment mais ces
gens là je suis particulièrement à leur
dire un grand merci pour la carrière qui
ont fait lyon tenue l'école à bout de
bras pendant des années on a véhiculé
grandes années de coupes eux les années
où on a des pots de services etc ont
continué à aider nos élèves chapeau à
ces gens là qui finissent de façon
particulière mais on ça nous permet de
voir à quel point l'éducation est une
priorité dans notre société il faudrait
que le gouvernement s'en rappellent pour
leur projet nicolas le ministre roberge
a été beaucoup critiquée pour ses
directives jugé souvent floues
changeantes beaucoup d'énergie dans le
réseau scolaire pour s'adapter aux
différentes consignes qui changeait
régulièrement ça a été tout un défi à
écouter c était vraiment un énorme défi
je peux vous dire que les directions
adjointes et directions d'école autant
primaire secondaire en formation des
adultes et en formation professionnelle
ont trouvé les trois derniers mois
ainsi disent il faut se lever beaucoup
beaucoup d'organisations beaucoup de
changements des directives qui ont
avancé ont reculé mais on a pu quand
même avoir la chance de nous exprimer
nous au niveau de la fkd d'en parler au
ministre de l'éducation de lui dire
qu'on souhaitait maintenant avoir d
orientation plus claire des balises plus
précisément en laissant aussi une marge
de manoeuvre aux centres de services aux
établissements
on voulait aussi terminé bien terminer
l'année ne pas avoir d'autres
changements pour s'assurer d'une bonne
fin d'année pour que les gens partent
dans un état d'esprit je vous dirai plus
plus serein et de l'eau se préparer
tranquillement profitez bien entendu des
vacances et se préparer pour l'an
prochain
mais oui ça a été pour les directions
des moments forts du film et on était au
rendez vous géométrie vraiment plus que
variable en matière de lien enseignants
élèves depuis
le 13 mars on a vraiment réalisé josé
que les enfants étaient pas égaux devant
l'apprentissage en ligne l'apprentissage
à distance
ça représentait un grand défi on n'était
pas prêt depuis des années on nous
disait que moment donné les nouvelles
technologies de les faire partie de nos
vies on en parlait beaucoup mais on
n'était pas prêt à ça on a eu à le vivre
on a dû servir et de bord rapidement
quand il ya eu le retour à l'école
c'était un soulagement pour beaucoup de
gens on a laissé le volontariat en se
retournant et là ne vous inquiétez pas
le juge aucun parent mais on sait que
des parents ont choisi de ne pas faire
son retour à l'école et depuis le début
de la pandémie on parlait vraiment
d'aider les plus vulnérables ce qu'on a
découvert il faudra faire un bilan avec
le gouvernement de cette rentrée là
qu'on a eu au moins mais qui pour des
enseignants ont été extraordinaires
grâce aux petits groupes qu'on avait la
possibilité qu'on était de s'occuper de
chacun de nos élèves qui étaient pas
venus à l'école depuis deux mois
parce qu'ils étaient peu nombreux on
pouvait prendre le temps de s'occuper
d'eux est par contre il ya des élèves
qu'on aurait voulu voir dans nos classes
et pour différents présent n'était pas
là et parmi ces élèves là tu avais des
élèves avec de grande vulnérabilité à
différents niveaux que ce soit pédagogie
ou toute autre raison
les enseignants disent ben on veut être
capable d'aider ces élèves là aussi
c'est dangereux qu'on s'apprête à dire
avec un retour à des classes normales
avec le même nombre d'élèves donc le
défilement exode toutes ces élèves là
pour nos pas été capable de rejoindre à
cause des technologies parce que des
parents ont choisi qui est répondent
ceux qui ont continué qu'elle est une
facilité avec les technologies qu'il
avait à la maison tout le matériel tant
mieux mais faut trouver une façon
d'aller aider nos plus vulnérables et on
a vu également des enseignants qui ont
été capables très créatif et d'être
rapidement en contact avec leurs élèves
et poursuivre tout au cours de la
pandémie
dites moi avec le recul souvent on dit
c'est facile après 1
dire on aurait dû faire si on aurait dû
faire ça mais quels enseignements
doit-on retenir de cette crise là
nicolas ont écouté je pense qu'on doit
plusieurs petites leçons à tirer de
cette crise de la paisible que vous
voyez bien entendu tout ce qui est bon
madame scalabrini ne parle un peu le
mais tout ce qui est des de la sphère
techno pédagogique de l'est est vraiment
de suivi de nos élèves et de leur
facilité à utiliser les les appareils
informatiques
la formation des enseignants si au
niveau techno pédagogique
puis il faudra aller de l'avant aussi à
ce niveau là qu'est-ce que l'aspect
aussi le corps on en discute on en parle
moins des fois c'est l'aspect
psychosocial aussi tous nos élèves qui
ont pu se retrouver bon avec un suivi
pas d'être moins série d'une loupe ou
éducateurs de nos psychologues se
retrouvaient pas tomber dans des moments
plus difficiles à la maison donc sauf si
ce lien l'autre de présence
c'est important c'est là qu'on voit que
la présence le physique est important
donc on a plusieurs leçons à tirer de
tout choix il faudra être et le pour la
prochaine fois se roule dans l'offre de
services d'information à distance
l'équipe était égal on a vu de très
belles choses mais malheureusement
l'objectif 3 avec son plus loin patrick
postis l'été sera co parce qu'on se
préparer pour la rentrée scolaire
également la possible deuxième vague
alors rester là après la pause
justement se pencher sur cette rentrée
scolaire pour tous les élèves dans tous
les établissements
ce sera en septembre